grace walk us through that moment when
they called your name what were you
going through what were you feeling
really whenever something like that
happens you're not really thinking
you're just like oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh grace vanderwaal is back as
star goal in the sequel to the disney
plus film and this time she is headed to
hollywood which i feel like you can
relate to grace maybe kind of a little
bit of it
[Applause]
damn so you want to be in our movie
no no i just
i just love the same
from obscurity thrown into hollywood
listen before we get into the movie
which i loved by the way uh we last saw
you person in march 2020 promoting star
girl the first movie yeah literally
right before the world imploded so over
the last two years like for you was it a
creative time god no it's more of like a
suffering time yes but you know what it
made us stronger that's right we came
out i'm feeling good i'm feeling great
the movie came out i'm thriving i'm
energetic you have a new hairstyle new
hairstyle it's grown a lot i can't
believe it's leave a link now i always
thought that was the type of person
where like my hair doesn't grow i'm
looking back i'm like damn do you miss
the shorter
i do i hair
i'm going to cut it today maybe okay i
don't know she's going to be looking
different tomorrow
well you look gorgeous uh you know in
the sequel star girl is not only in a
new town but there's new friends there's
a new boy talk to me about how hollywood
star girl is kind of like a love letter
to l.a and also the creatives who live
here oh my gosh it's such a love letter
to l.a i feel like everyone focuses on
the bad parts of l.a
you know what i'm saying yes but you
know uh like the truth is that there
there is like a really really nice
element to la of like
you're just surrounded around like
people
who are like you and you can make
creative things you know what i'm saying
you don't even live here but you still
appreciate what los angeles is i can
apprec this movie has opened my eyes i'm
like damn yeah
i take that for granted
write your own stuff no i just really
like other people's stuff you're gonna
have to figure out your own thing
you've actually filmed in a bunch of
locations that i've actually frequented
but i don't know i saw it through a new
lan i thought through star girl's eyes
yeah you were like oh that is pretty
that is pretty cool that i go here and i
or i live here like the hollywood
forever cemetery screen and i was like
oh my god like that is probably one of
the best things to do in l.a i love that
was featured in the moment i know i wish
we actually did it i know it's all fake
well this summer make it happen this
summer yeah um i'm spoiler alert but you
actually sing with uma thurman yes
like what what no i know
what do you remember about that
experience i don't know i mean i wasn't
a part of it like making it obviously
they just told me that was happening i
was like okay like that that's awesome
and it was super cool she's really
really cool and quirky and just like
awesome and i can't believe that i can
say that now that you're saying with um
thurman you seem like a kill bill fan
are you oh my god yes kill bill pulp
fiction it's just like insane she's an
icon it was really really crazy but you
do get a really cool version of uma in
this movie you guys will love the scene
uh so uh star girl in the sequel is
acting and so she's like singing and
acting yeah she's getting into it again
i feel like art is imitating life a
little bit yeah definitely now is that
something you still want to do both
acting and singing
i
don't know i'm a very go with the flow
type gal
so whatever pops up pops up we'll see
you know as many people know you
actually won america's got talent in
2016. what they don't realize is i was
covering the show for e.t
back then too so i thought it'd be fun
if we watched a clip from the night that
you won which by the way will be just as
embarrassing for me as it is let's take
a look let's do it
grace walk us through that moment when
they called your name what were you
going through what were you feeling
really whenever something like that
happens you're not really thinking
you're just like oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my gosh this is happening
this is happening this is happening this
happening
i regret that immediately oh my gosh oh
my gosh oh my god i'm so cute you were
12 years old when you went agt yeah that
was a fun night for us though that was a
fun night yeah i was like on such and
trembling i
remember i like blacked out i remember
you telling me you wanted to spend the
prize money on a tree house which you
did right i did that so do you still
have that tree house
dude you know what's so messed up no is
it gone what happened to it oh no
my parents moved so i'm putting that's
on them that is not my problem
all i wanted was to dream crazy things
and find people crazy enough to dream
them with me let's get into your life
and career i mean last year you released
the song don't assume what you don't
know yeah um which i feel like was
really all about the fantasies of
hollywood
i feel like star girls idea of fame is
probably different than what grace
vanderwaal thinks of fame yeah right
well yeah star girls world is
very perfect and we love that for her we
absolutely love that for her
wouldn't want it any other way but yeah
reality is maybe a little bit have you
kind of come to terms with like your
fame and you know you've been in the the
business for a couple years now yeah you
know i think that it's an ongoing
struggle always it's really it's hard
and it's been really really hard growing
up
the way that i have
but you know that's what this like i'm
making new music and it's all about like
my
kind of filtered experience that i've
never really
been able to talk about so
it's very nerve-wracking and exciting
but like i feel like that's how i cope
with it is just put it in music
absolutely i love it how do you feel
like your sound has evolved too since
when you first started like recording
your own stuff oh god
how's my zombies i first started
recording you still have that smoky and
silver like voice but absolutely you're
writing yeah yeah and i i think that
it'll constantly change and like i'm
always
getting inspired by like new creative
ways to write and express myself and
just like the most satisfying way where
it's like yeah that is how i feel yeah
for sure love and mercy i love your
singing thank you
i'm evan i'm star girl well you turned
18 in january congrats 18 years old it's
so crazy i met her when she was 12 and
now you're an adult it's so cool we
really did we really did now is that
when you got your tattoos like when you
turned 18. i well
i've been getting tattoos for a while i
this was actually like bob grace can you
even imagine that i've been i've been
this way for a while wow yeah bob grace
in her tree house this is like i want to
be a geyser
you all you have that edge too but um i
got no i got these when i was 18 because
it's like a butterfly and transformation
i love it i love it okay so we need some
live updates uh you're no longer in
south carolina
right you're and you're not in l.a no
where are you these days i am georgia
okay
georgia right now she's in the south
still y'all and are you done with school
uh yes you are okay i remember you
saying that you wanted to be a kooky
middle school teacher oh yeah i would
still if this doesn't work out
maybe who knows you have your backup
plan that is my backup okay i love it uh
you mentioned new music is on the
horizon what can you tease like what
does this next era of grace vanderwaal
looks like look like i
just you know i'm 18. i can i can open
up a lot more about things and i feel
like i my life can be very romanticized
and it has been so
i mean absolutely i'm literally staying
here it seems like a dream it is a dream
it's been amazing to watch you grow and
i can't wait to see you evolve even more
and i said this to you when you were 12
years old at agt but you are a star so i
can't wait to see what you do next girl
thank you very much you too oh in the
meantime you guys can catch hollywood
star girl that is streaming now on
disney plus
[Music]